[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lorsque l'on parle de droit on imagine
qu'il poursuit un idéal de justice
naïvement on croit que le droit prendra
en compte l'intérêt de l'ensemble des
individus ceux qui sont placés plutôt
dans une situation de force et ceux qui
sont plutôt placé dans une situation de
faiblesse on pense que le droit
parviendrez à une conciliation équitable
de ses intérêts et donc à la
satisfaction de tous
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen de 1789 dispose que la
liberté consiste à faire tout ce qui ne
nuit pas à autrui
dès lors ma liberté et mon action serait
seulement limité par le droit à partir
du moment où elles nuiraient à autrui
d'où la célèbre citation ma liberté
s'arrête là où commence celle des autres
alors lorsque l'on dit cela il est
nécessaire de déterminer les contours du
terme autrui mais qui est autrui autrui
c'est l'autre que moi on croit
généralement que c'est seulement l'autre
êtres humains ou l'autre homme
en réalité la définition d'autrui est
beaucoup plus large elle en gaule
elle englobe l'ensemble des individus
vivant sensible
cela devrait donc nous amener à élargir
le champ de notre considération de
l'autre
évidemment à l'homme mais aussi à
l'animal alors le droit dans sa quête de
justice et dans la prise en compte des
intérêts de chacun des individus doit
toutefois appliqué un principe de
proportionnalité
vous serez d'accord avec moi pour
considérer que tous les intérêts ne se
valent pas l'intérêt à vivre d'un
individu n'est pas équivalent à
l'intérêt d'un autre individu a éprouvé
quelques secondes de plaisir
si par exemple quelques secondes de
plaisir implique la mort d'un autre
individu le droit interviendra
évidemment pour refuser au premier
individu le droit de tuer le second et
ce quand bien même il s'agirait de votre
belle-mère insupportable ou d'un voisin
très bruyant je pense que vous serez
d'accord avec cela et que cette solution
vous paraît assez claire et évidente
maintenant reprenons cette hypothèse
mais remplaçons le premier individu pas
cet individu à gauche qui paraît en
bonne santé
plutôt musclé et le second individu par
cet individu à droite qui est un joli
agneaux imaginons que le premier
individu de gauche souhaite faire son
repas du petit agneau parce que il a un
plaisir pour la viande d'agneau
l'intérêt du premier individu a éprouvé
quelques secondes de plaisir gustatif
doit-il prévaloir sur l'intérêt à vivre
du second individu à droite
l'honnêteté intellectuelle devrait vous
amener dans les deux hypothèses que je
viens de citer à la même solution
mais rassurez vous l'application du
droit pas alors je vais vous exposer en
quelques minutes la façon dont notre
droit gère la conciliation des intérêts
de l'homme et ceux de l'animal
la première loi de protection des
animaux date de 1850 c'est la loi
grammont
elle a été portée par victor hugo que
l'on connaît comme étant un grand
défenseur des droits de l'homme mais que
l'on connaît - comme étant également un
grand défenseur des animaux
cependant la loi g ans n'a eu que de
façon incidente pour effet de protéger
les animaux puisque la vocation première
de cette loi était de protéger les
humains de la vision des mauvais
traitements qu'ils étaient infligés aux
animaux
c'est la raison pour laquelle seuls les
mauvais traitements qu'ils étaient
commis en public était sanctionné alors
que les mauvais traitements qu'ils
étaient commis en privé ne l'était pas
pour les mêmes raisons la corrida a été
interdite en 1886 par waldeck-rousseau
parce qu'elles portaient atteinte à la
moralité publique
il a fallu attendre les années 1950 pour
que l'animal soit protégé pour lui même
c'est à dire en tant qu'individu
susceptibles de souffrir des mauvais
traitements dont ils pouvaient être
victimes
ainsi à partir des années 1950 les
mauvais traitements deviennent protéger
à la fois s'ils sont commis en public
mais également en privé en 1976 le code
rural a reconnu le caractère d'être
sensible des animaux en obligeant leurs
propriétaires à les placer dans des
conditions compatibles avec les
impératifs biologiques de leur espèce
c'est l'article l214 de ce code
ainsi à côté des dispositions générales
de protection des mauvais traitements
infligés aux animaux qui sont prévues
par le code pénal
il existe tout un corpus de règles
juridiques qui ont vocation à protéger
l'animal dans des circonstances où
l'homme est le plus à même d'y porter
atteinte
en effet le droit pour délicate mission
de concilier des intérêts pour le moins
divergents l'intérêt de l'animal aviv à
ne pas souffrir et l'intérêt de l'homme
qui revendique lui de pouvoir utiliser
exploiter et tuer l'animal alors pour
parvenir à cette équation plutôt
compliqué a été développé le concept de
bien-être animal au sens générique le
bien-être est définie par le
dictionnaire comme l'état agréable de
satisfaction des besoins du corps et du
calme de l'esprit alors quand l'on
entend cette définition est qu'il faut
l'appliquer aux animaux on imagine
quelque chose comme dans cette vidéo
la réalité est comme vous le savez tout
autre pour appliquer des règles de
bien-être des animaux dans des élevages
tels que ceux que vous voyez à l'écran
élevage de poules en cage ou élevage de
cochons
il a fallu procéder à une redéfinition
de la notion de bien-être et cette
redéfinition nous a été donnée par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
animale les yeux qui a fait reposer le
principe de bien-être animal sur cinq
obligations l'obligation que l'animal ne
doit pas souffrir de faim et de soif qui
ne doit pas souffrir d'un confort qu'il
ne doit pas souffrir de blessures ou de
maladies qui doit pouvoir exprimer des
comportements naturels et qu'il ne doit
pas souffrir de peur ou de détresse
lorsque l'on entend cette définition
on a l'impression d'être plus proche de
la survie que de la sérénité
alors notre droit à créer des règles
pour assurer une protection des animaux
dans les situations comme je l'aï
indiqué où l'homme est le plus
susceptible de porter atteinte en
élevage par exemple prenons les cas des
poules pondeuses en cages avant 2012 les
poules pondeuses disposés par poule
d'une superficie minimale de cinq cent
cinquante centimètres carrés alors 550
ça paraît beaucoup
cinq cent cinquante centimètres carrés
c'est ça c'est une feuille a4
mais ça c'était avant 2012 depuis 2012
la situation des poules s'est grandement
améliorée depuis 2012 elle dispose à
présent toujours de cette feuille a4
mais aussi d'une carte postale
je vous rappelle comme vous le savez que
70% des oeufs consommées en france
proviennent de poules élevées en cage et
que cela représente 47 millions de
poules par an en france
prenons le cas de l'élevage de cochons
les cochons sont des animaux curieux
intelligent qui dans leur milieu naturel
parce 75% de leur journée à des
activités de type free cement recherche
de nourriture exploration évidemment en
bâtiment ils ne peuvent pas se livrer à
cette activité
notre droit est donc intervenu pour leur
trouver des substituts
c'est ce que l'on appelle pompeusement
l'enrichissement du milieu alors qu'est
ce que c'est l'enrichissement du milieu
et bien par exemple c'est cette chaîne
cette chaîne qui est approché dans un
parc où sont les cochons pour qu'ils
puissent s'amuser
je vous rappelle comme vous savez que
95% des cochons en france vivent dans
des bâtiments et qui ne verront la
lumière du jour qu'une seule fois dans
leur vie
le jour ils seront envoyés à l'abattoir
et l'abattoir parlons-en
notre droit aussi imaginer qu'il puisse
y avoir des règles de protection et de
bien-être des animaux dans les abattoirs
il a par exemple prévu un principe d'
étourdissements obligatoire préalable
des animaux
alors quand on entend le terme
étourdissements ça nous rappelle
quelques petits souvenirs tête qui
tourne
j'ai un peu trop bu
pour les animaux l'étourdissement se
concrétise un tout petit peu
différemment qu'avec quelques verres de
bon bordeaux de trop est ce que je vais
vous dire je crois que ça ne va pas vous
plaire pour les animaux l'étourdissement
se concrétise par exemple par un
pistolet at ease perforantes qui est
placé sur la tête du bovin et qui
perfore son crâne on parle également de
pincer à l'électronarcose qui sont des
pinces des électrodes placées sur les
tempes de l'animal le mouton ou le
cochon et qui le traverse dans courant
électrique de fortes intensités
naturellement on parle également de bain
d'eau qui n'est pas la possibilité pour
un animal allé faire un petit plongeon
dans un étang du bocage
mais qui est le fait de plonger un
animal une volaille en l'occurrence dans
un d'un traversé par un courant
électrique
on parle enfin de dioxyde de carbone
c'est à dire le fait de faire descendre
les cochons dans une fosse remplie de
co2 ce qui leur provoque des graves
irritation pulmonaires et des
suffocations jusqu'à leur perte de
conscience
mais attendez soyons bien clairs
rassurez vous je vous parle toujours du
droit et des règles que le droit a prévu
pour assurer la protection et le
bien-être des animaux
je ne me permettrais évidemment pas de
vous décrire des techniques barbare et
là encore ce sont les plus chanceux qui
ont droit à ces techniques
d'autres n'ont même pas le droit à
l'étourdissement il ya par exemple
l'abattage sans étourdissement dit
abattages rituels mais il y a également
le cas des poussins mâles dit en
surnombre alors pourquoi en surnombre et
bien parce que pour l'élevage de poules
pondeuses
les mâles sont inutiles alors je ne vous
apprendrai pas que les mâles ne pompe
pas d'oeuf
donc étant inutiles ils sont broyés
vivant et conscient
cela représente 50 millions de poussins
mâles par an en france
dans l'élevage dans la production de
foie gras
ce sont les femelles qui sont inutiles
puisque on a besoin que des mâles elles
aussi sont broyés alors avec après ces
quelques explications vous aurez
aisément compris
je donnais un coup de pied à un animal
c'est un mauvais traitements puni par
notre code pénal d'une infraction de 4e
classe
par contre tu es un animal avec un
couteau
c'est parfaitement légal cela nous
renvoie à une autre croyance qui est que
le droit se seraient proportionnelles à
la gravité des faits cela nous renvoie
également une autre croyance que le
droit serait logique et cohérent par
exemple prenez l'exemple d'une corrida
la corrida est un acte de cruauté un
sévices graves si grave qu'il est puni
par notre code pénal de deux ans
d'emprisonnement et de 30000 euros
d'amendé
sur les neuf dixièmes de notre
territoire français ainsi une corrida
qui sera organisé à nantes serait puni
de deux ans d'emprisonnement
par contre la même corrida organisée à
dax pas de problème
de la même façon on pense que le droit
très très de la même façon un même
animal
prenez l'exemple du lapins de compagnie
de votre enfant qui aurait eu la
malchance d'être maltraitée par un
voisin
cet animal ce lapin serait protégé et le
voisin maltraitant seraient susceptibles
d'être poursuivis devant les
juridictions répressives
prenez par contre maintenant ce même
lapin en liberté qui se baladerait dans
la campagne il aurait la malchance de
tomber sur un individu peu recommandable
qui le maltraitent e rey et bien cet
animal ce lapin ne serait pas protéger
des mauvais traitements et son auteur ne
pourrait faire l'objet d'aucune
poursuite
en effet notre droit ne protège pas les
animaux sauvages
alors tout cela nous rappelle une phrase
d'edgar morin qui disait qu' il y a
moins de désordre dans la nature qu'il y
en a dans l'humanité alors qu'est ce que
vous croyez que le droit protège
vraiment les animaux
[Applaudissements]